andrew i got a two-parter for you right
now
because i believe this is your first
feature since
even starting walking dead so i was
wondering
one why choose to focus on walking dead
and not load up your schedule with
movies in between
seasons and also after having had an
experience focusing on
that show for so long even though the
material here is completely different
is there anything about that experience
that you find coming in handy in the
project you take on now
great questions i mean the first
question is
i i have a young family and
uh you know the industry is littered
with
you know people that don't make it as a
family and and and i spent eight months
away from them for a loss of their
childhood
uh and i it was becoming
more unbearable so i would you know so
basically when i was home
uh i was playing catch up as a parent as
a husband and
as a father uh and also you know
unfortunately what hap what you have to
do is you have to
change people's uh perceptions of what
you're
able to do as an actor and so a lot of
the scripts i was receiving
were great scripts but they were action
and they were horror
and um and i just thought you know what
i
i was waiting for the right stories to
chime
uh and then this one came along and i
instantly loved it knew i wanted to be a
part of this beautiful story of
you know the bloom family and then we
know he was involved and yadda yadda it
just was a no-brainer uh
what i i've learned working in america
uh i will i i think i improved as an
actor working in america
working at the scale that our show was
on and working with really
really fine uh filmic axes in america
you know it's great being trained in the
uk
um but there's something about working
with
really the best on screen
that kind of ups your game and and the
alchemy of just sort of
the endeavor of trying to get it better
there isn't a set
way of doing it uh and that was
something that certainly working with
this
there's never a set way of working with
children and animals
and so yeah i think you learn as you go
and you grow
as hopefully as an actor as you get more
experience